die E.ON einer der größten
Versorgungsbetriebe hat jetzt gerade
Milliarden und ziemlich 8 Milliarden
Euro Gewinn gemeldet bei RWE werden es
5,5 sein beide haben ca 2 Millionen mehr
als erwartet haben sind also sozusagen
die kriegsgewinner und ja das stößt mir
ganz sauer auf den die diese Betriebe
sind die gehen ja sein staatlichen
Konsensus hervor sind jetzt
privatwirtschaftlich geführt aber
trotzdem könnte ich mir doch etwas eine
soziale Verantwortung vorstellen wenn
man daran denkt dass er hier die soziale
Marktwirtschaft mehr oder weniger
erfunden wurde seither hat was ist denn
an dieser Marktwirtschaft aus dem
Bürgern das alles abgereimt wird damit
sich einige wenige bereichern können
nämlich die die entweder Aktien haben
oder die dort in Verantwortung sind und
große Gagen kassieren dass sich die
bereichern können so einfach darf man
sich nicht machen und ich glaube dass
man diese übergewinne sehr wohl steuern
muss da gibt es einen Beschluss und ich
hoffe dass das bald soweit ist aber
eigentlich können die Bürger sich doch
bei den Gewinnen eine Flasche Champagner
aufmachen bei hoher Gewinne bedeuten ja
schon hohe Steuern in diesem Land also
ist ja nicht so als wenn die Konzerne
jetzt das Geld nehmen und sagen so das
sind jetzt hier meine Milliarden und ihr
kriegt nichts davon das ist ja bei den
Firmen nicht so Möglichkeiten dieser
großen Konzerne sind so phänomenalter
die mir keine Freude bereitet dass ich
mich darauf freuen kann dass so viele
Milliarden jetzt zurückgehen in den
staatssegel es ist einfach das rundherum
glaube ich ist unbedingt wichtig
geben sie offen zu das ist ja gar nicht
das ist wieder bei den
benzinfirmensteuereinnahmen die wir
jemals hatten
weil viele Menschen Arbeit sind im
Bruder und Arbeit der kleine Arbeiter
der dort verdient oder ein bisschen
mitarbeitet und die wird immer mehr
geworden sind die werden zur Kasse
geboten die müssen ihre Stromrechnung
sein ihre Gasrechnung zahlen und die die
da oben sitzen und ein gutes Leben
führen nutzen eine Kriegssituation aus
damit sie endlich auch noch mehr Gewinne
abschöpfen können das halte ich für
zutiefst nicht nur manchmal
akzeptabel
reinmachen es ist ja immer dieser
Argument dieses vielleicht kann man es
auch Vorurteilen oder Argumente das
müssen sie mal beantworten dass die
Energiekonzerne diese hohen Gewinnen nur
durch den Ukraine Krieg haben ist es
denn wirklich so oder waren die
Energiepreise auch schon vorher sehr
hoch nein die Energiepreise waren schon
vorher sehr hoch das wissen wir ja
eigentlich seit 2021 und wir haben
natürlich auch das Problem bei der
Rückgabe dass sie ja die Energiekonzerne
Energie an den Börsen Einkaufen wir aber
sozusagen Abnahmeverträge haben auf die
jetzt reagiert wurde deswegen hat ja die
Bundesregierung ja auch Maßnahmenpaket
beschlossen und das sozusagen für die
privat Personen abzufangen aber
damit das Konzerne ordentliche Preise
verlangen können die jetzt die Regierung
dann wieder zurückgibt den Konzernen
also wenn sich jemand mit Konzernen und
Freital Wirtschaft auskennt dann
wahrscheinlich die Republik Österreich
aber ich glaube da ist es schon so dass
man ein bisschen mal bei den Fakten
bleiben sollte und der ruft danach
passiert schnell es gibt aber kein
fachliches und sachliches Argument weil
erklären Sie mir doch definieren Sie
doch mal bitte nach einem rechtlichen
Rahmen was denn für sie eine übersteuert
sein sollte also wir brauchen die also
wir müssen es in den Gesetzen erklären
sich jetzt von der fdp-linie nein
beschlossen wir haben keine
übergewinnsteuer beschlossen nein die
Hälfte so ein bisschen anders hat aber
genau denselben Inhalt nein so ist es ja
auch nicht korrekt also wir haben ja die
übergewinnsteuer deswegen auch abgelehnt
weil man nicht definieren kann was ein
übergewinn ist also auch das Wort Krisen
Gewinner ist ja schon schwierig was ist
denn für sieben Krisen Gewinner als
Corona wir hatten
zu Ungunsten der Gesellschaft aber um
eine Situation einfach um eine Situation
auszunutzen muss ich ja zumindest mal
den Vorsatz haben dass ich aus der
Situation auch aus eigenem Kraft
irgendwas gestalten kann wahrscheinlich
auch sehr sehr subjektiv das zu
definieren also wenn es wirklich nur um
um die Absicht geht in der Situation
dann muss man wie will man das dann
entscheiden indem in dem Fall wenn wir
Bayern Tag ja auch ein Krisen gehen
gewesen kann man sagen da sind es auch
sehr sehr viel Geld gemacht weil also wo
fängt man da bei dir an Hans als
Industriestandort wo greifen von
Benzinpreisen wir kennen uns doch bitte
auf der Mineralien irgendwie Wirtschaft
ja es werden dann wenn die normalen
Ölpreise steigen steigt immer sofort
auch der Benzinpreis kaum gehen die
runter haben wir noch eingekauft die
alten Benzinpreise Italien und die neuen
können wir erst wieder später
zurückgeben am Wochenende um Gottes
Willen wieder mehr Leute da werden die
Benzinpreise aufgeräumt und so weiter
man nennt das Marktwirtschaft das
Verstehen ja aber es gibt doch sowas wie
soziale Marktwirtschaft auf das hier so
stolz sind drauf und vielleicht sollte
man da noch einmal fragen ob es nicht
auch anders ginge als dass man den
Bürger den letzten 10 aus dem Segel
zieht nur damit mehr Gewinne auf der
portenseite von meinem Parkgebühr
Konzerne stehen können die da vielleicht
wieder Spenden geben irgendwelchen
Parteien das kann ja auch möglich sein
nicht das kann man ja nicht aber wer
zieht denn dem Bürger wirklich das Geld
aus der Tasche das ist ja und die
Energie kommt
ja gerade noch festgestellt also wir
haben so Einnahmen also Deutschland ist
ja eh Platz 2 was Steuern betrifft also
Herr baust einen Einnahmen also wenn wir
jetzt mal darauf kommen und sagen ja wir
finden über gewünscht gut brauchen wir
überhaupt noch mehr Einnahmen oder
schafft der Staat einfach nicht ist
gerecht zu verteilen ja also wir
generieren ja Start Einnahmen wenn wir
vernünftig anfangen zu wirtschaften und
dazu muss ich und das ist meine tiefe
Überzeugung den Menschen natürlich auch
die Luft lassen dass die wirtschaftlich
vernünftig tätig sein können in Freiraum
zu geben und ja die Debatte die wir
gerade dazu führen zum Bundeshaushalt
ist ja genau die spannende Debatte
wollen wir einen überbordenden Staat wo
der Staat wir hatten gerade das Thema
Verantwortung sämtliche Verantwortung
von dem Individuum nimmt oder haben wir
sozusagen Eigenverantwortung und wenn
ich mir angucke was auf uns zukommt saß
er hier schon öfter auf diesem Stuhl
allein demografische Geschichten dann
werden wir viele Mittel brauchen aber
ich muss halt vielleicht auch meine
Ausgaben überprüfen und die
übergewinnsteuer das mit Verlaub es ist
ein populistischer Vorschlag der jetzt
gut klingt ja aber die kleinen Leute
würden doch viel besser davon wenn ich
mal weil ihre Ausgaben überprüfen das
finde
ich
überprüfen die Staatsausgaben
ein begrenzten Zeitraum richtig die über
Gewinnsteuer
aber schauen wir uns doch mal im
internationalen Kontext an zum Beispiel
Italien hat die übergewinnsteuer
eingeführt 25% auf den Umsatz müssen da
die Konzerne ob das Umsatz oder Gewinn
ist wird doch überhaupt nicht mehr
berücksichtigt also wo sind wir denn das
ist im Grunde nichts anderes als eine
Enteignung das können wir ja bitte eine
Frage Frau Speaker gerne stellen wenn
man sich die Firma jetzt anschaut und
sagt die Energiekonzern diesen böse böse
Kriegsgewinnler um jetzt mal in dem in
dem sprech zu bleiben wo machen wir dann
weiter also ist Prophete weniger wert
wenn er keine gute Absicht hatte ist
Profit Mehrwert also wenn jemand dann
was tolles macht dann kriegt er eine
plus Gewinnsteuer oder wo würden sie da
ansetzen ich glaube das kann man nicht
machen das ist viel zu subjektiv das
muss ein Daten also wie bei dem Thema
Corona muss es irgendwie datenbasiert
sein dass man sagt das ist die Regel es
ist uns egal was die Absicht eines
bestimmten Unternehmens gewesen ist weil
das kann man ja man kann lügen man kann
sonst was behalten nicht
ich weiß nicht ob ich das so sagen und
nee ich weiß nicht ob ich das so sagen
würde
also
auch Gewinne gemacht jetzt sieht man auf
die Impfung mittlerweile anders weil man
da jetzt eine übergewinnsteuer einführt
das weiß ich nicht wie das funktionieren
soll oder auch die Umwandlung ne
Lieferdienste z.B Online Shopping was
hatten sie da plötzlich Unternehmen die
plötzlich Gewinnerwartungen hatten in
der Zeit als wir in der Pandemie waren
die dann auch unter ihre
übergewinnsteuer weil die krisengewinde
durch Zufall sind weil es eine Pandemie
gibt wenn man wenn man schon das Thema
so anpackt dann darf ich vielleicht
darauf hinweisen dass man ein bisschen
Marktwirtschaft kreieren sollte ja
absolut Vorteil auch für die FDP zum
Beispiel ja wir kommen wenn Sie heute
wechseln wollen von einem Stromanbieter
zum anderen brauche sie mehrere Monate
bis sie das tun können ich habe jetzt
gewechselt das hat gedauert drei Monate
die Ersparnis ist bitte
30%, 30 %. ja bei mir ich hätte das auch
so leisten können wahrscheinlich aber
für jeden der wirklich also eng da wäre
bei der Kasse ist für den ist das riesig
viel und das geht aber nicht da brauchen
wir drei Monate dazu wenn ich bin ziehen
kaufe dann kann er einmal zu schälen
gehen und das nächste Mal bedanke ich
also bei BB oder sonst irgendwo aber die
großen Konzerne die Schützen wir
natürlich weil die haben so viele
Investitionen ganz ganz da muss man
aufpassen dass die Jahr lange
Benzinpreis
wie setzt sich denn der Benzinpreis
zusammen
aber wenn ich heute über den hohen
Benzinpreis rede also ich habe auch eine
Verantwortung Klimaschutz und sowas also
das muss ich schon austarieren ich habe
ja viele Interessen aber ich muss
natürlich schon auch fragen wo ich
sozusagen also wo sich auch der Start
bedient und wenn wir zum Beispiel beim
Thema ich hasse dieses Wort das kleinen
Mannes weil das hat nichts mit kleinen
Mann zu tun das haben sie vorhin gerade
gesagt ähm aber dann lassen Sie uns doch
mal an das Thema Lohnnebenkosten gehen
lassen Sie uns doch mal an das Thema
Einkommensteuer gehen lassen Sie uns
doch mal an das Thema warum muss ich
eine Rente wieder versteuern obwohl ich
ja das schon mal irgendwie in meinem
Leben erwirtschaftet reden also da
steckt viel viel mehr Punkte drin als
bei einer über
dem Finanzminister gehört das nächste
Mal machen
sie abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
ihren
falls kämpft für Sie